it was a truly wacky weekend out of the
white house a Donald Trump suffering a
bizarre and strange meltdown over a
story from The Washington Post about
tweets and it caused them to send out
even crazier tweets so on Saturday the
Washington Post wrote about Donald
Trump's racist tweets on Sunday almost
like a full day later Trump spent his
morning losing his mind over the
Washington Post story and one of the
themes of that Washington Post article
which was extensively sourced despite
the tweets you're about to see
Washington Post did a really good job 26
White House aides advisors lawmakers and
others who were involved in handling
Trump's response to the hole go back to
their original countries Fiasco
basically shared the same perspective
with the Washington Post and the
perspective was Trump didn't and doesn't
even understand why what he said and did
was controversial and problematic like
the guy just genuinely doesn't get it
the Washington Post story tweeted Donald
Trump about my speech in North Carolina
and tweet with it's phony sources who do
not exist is fake news the only thing
people were talking about is the
record-setting crowd and the tremendous
enthusiasm far greater than the
Democrats you'll see in 2020 so the
North Carolina rally he's referring to
is that rally where the crowd chanted
send her back when Donald Trump
mentioned ethnic minority congresswoman
Ilhan Omar and Trump stood there looking
quite pleased and making no effort to
interrupt it which will play an
important role later on in the show
then on Sunday morning Donald Trump
tweeted quote presidential harassment
which is Trump's code word for a free
press reporting about what the president
does and as an integral and key part of
our system of government not an
institution that we should be attacking
that's that's what Trump means when he
says presidential harassment he doesn't
like a free press and then a couple of
minutes later Donald Trump tweeting
again quote I don't believe the for
Congress women are capable of loving our
country they should apologize to America
and Israel for the horrible hateful
things they have said they are
destroying the Democrat Party but our
weak
and insecure people who can never
destroy our great nation so let's
explore this for what it is when Trump
calls something fake news that is a
statement that is of no value Trump has
said he's admitted that fake news is
news he doesn't like or news that is
critical of him so that ship has sailed
calling something fake news is of no
meaning or value whatsoever the problem
is that the meme of fake news has
metastasized we have a poll which shows
that 42% of Republicans believe that a
story that is accurate but critical of
the president is quote fake news that's
the crisis that's one of the crises the
other crisis is that once again the
constant and never-ending
misunderstandings about free speech and
censorship and most importantly in this
case press freedom are truly damaging to
our democracy free speech does not mean
freedom from the consequences of speech
I've said this before many of you will
find it repetitive Donald Trump seems to
think that he can say outrageous racist
xenophobic things and that for it to be
free speech it has to be immune from any
consequences which includes media
writing stories about it the speech that
is people and media reacting to Trump
Trump and what Trump says is just as
important as Donald Trump's speech
itself it's arguably more important I
would actually argue because Trump has
the power and the influence of the bully
pulpit as president of the United States
it's the role of people it's the role of
voters it's the role of media to
counteract those things when necessary
or desirable lastly as usual Donald
Trump seemingly very wound up by lots of
bad things going on for him this week
that is another you know in the back of
all these things when you look at the
timing it took 24 hours for Donald Trump
to start tweeting about this Washington
Post article why well it was Sunday
going into what may not be a good week
for Donald Trump robert muller is
scheduled to testify Wednesday we will
see if that ultimately happens every
indication that it will and obviously
Donald Trump is panicking documents from
the original Jeff
epstein case may be unsealed and it's
likely that trump figures in those
documents number three the Iran Fiasco
has just completely imploded on Trump
and Trump has now been personally
implicated in hush money payments and
some newly released documents so it's
not been a good week it's shaping
shaping up to be a very bad week for
Donald Trump and we have to understand
that every time these tweet storms
happen that seem to make not much sense
especially when it's been like a full
day could have been that he saw
something on Fox News that reminded him
of it don't want to you know ignore that
possibility but there is almost always a
scandal that Donald Trump is eager to
distract from and unhinged tweets to
take control of the news cycle are a
common way that he tries to do that make
sure you were following me on instagram
at david pakman I do to bribers slowly
climbing were set to hit 700 thousand
YouTube subscribers today check that out
on my Instagram and while you're there
follow the show on instagram at david
pakman show if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by skill share and we're
giving you two entire months of free
access to skills share when you click
the link underneath this video skill
share is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a
out of it Pat has taken some courses
that he's found really valuable and I
think you'll love it to get started for
free by clicking the link under this
video